droht dem indischen ozean jetzt die mega
ölkatastrophe das havarierte frachter
cassio dass er tagen vor mauritius öl
verliert droht in zwei teile zu
zerbrechen
1180 tonnen schweröl haben das
türkisblaue wasser und die schneeweißen
strände des inselparadies bereits
versorgt nach bild-informationen riss
ein bereits leer gepumpte tank doch
umweltaktivist brüno lloret erklärt im
bild interview
das für weitere tanks mit schweröl
gefüllt sind momentan ist das meer ruhig
wenn der wellengang aber zunimmt erklärt
er weiter
dann wird es gefährlich versuche den
frachter wieder flott zu machen
scheiterten mehr als 1000 480 tonnen öl
wurden eingesammelt oder aus dem schiff
gepumpt doch die katastrophe ist kaum
noch aufzuhalten noch immer sind 1800
tonnen treibstoff in den tanks die nun
geleert werden sollen bevor die
ölkatastrophe zum super-gau wird iwf
experte jörn ehlers zu bild brachte
fahren mit schweröl einem besonders
giftigen treibstoff der an land gar
nicht mehr verbrannt werden darf
es ist überfällig dass man diese
schweröl verbietet durch andere
treibstoffe ersetzt
mit besen und schaufeln versuchen
inselbewohner ihre strände vom ölteppich
zu befreien
laut wwf expertin ehlers seien die
einheimischen darauf nicht vorbereitet
gewesen
obwohl allein im juli 2000 frachter
vorbeigefahren sind mein kollege bild in
münchen chef daniel cremer war erst vor
kurzem noch auf mauritius ja wir haben
auch bilder davon ist mich dort mit
delfinen geschwommen wir sehen hier die
bilder ja und er liebt dieses
urlaubsparadies und der ist mir jetzt
live zugeschaltet guten morgen daniel
gordon sina daniel was geht in dir vor
wenn du diese bilder von dieser
umweltkatastrophe siehst ja das ist das
ist ganz komisch freunde haben mir auch
schon gesagt ich bekomme jetzt auch wenn
ich die bilder sehe euch die augen weil
es einfach so traurig ist was da
passiert diese wunderbare insel diese
dieser diese wunderbaren menschen und
auch diese wunderbare tierwelt wo man
das ist fast einmalig in der welt dass
man mit wilden delfinen zu schwimmen
kann wie dort ja ich bin unendlich
traurig ich habe das
bei anderen umweltkatastrophen noch nie
so erlebt aber das trifft mich trifft
mich wahnsinnig während du kennst die
gegend sehr gut weil soeben erst vor
kurzem dort fast was geht denn da alles
verloren jetzt durch diese
umweltkatastrophe
naja so ich war insgesamt fünf mal auf
mauritius und es ist so das ist eine
sehr alte in die ihn sagt kein militär
die die die indischstämmige die weiße
und schwarze bevölkerung leben da in
frieden zusammen noch über die religion
es gibt keine großen zum beispiel
tourismus firmen die dort aktiv sind das
sind alles kleine fischer zum beispiel
der uno der mich immer mitgenommen hat
wie lange die ihr leben gespart haben
auch so ein brot und für die geht alles
verloren
das fischen natürlich einmal die fischer
liest natürlich auch immer ein ergebnis
essen
man kann da am strand sitzen und wenn
man siegel markt das praktisch aus dem
aus dem aus dem wasser nehmen und und
das ist ist es für mich unbeschreiblich
ich weiß nicht wie das gehen soll
abseits von der großindustrie des
tourismus sondern für die für die für
die leute da ich es ist mein mann kann
sich das gar nicht vorstellen ich wenn
ich dir freunden sage ich sage immer
muss sich vorstellen als wenn hier
nochmal tschernobyl passieren würde
so so so wird es sein wie jetzt in der
westlichen welt im atomkraftwerk
explodiert so anders kann ich es mir
nicht erklären